I think there's an incredibly disgusting
Concept in the society that says nice
guys finish last I think it's an awful
thing as a matter of fact I really need
to make a hoodie and start rocking it
that says nice guys finish first because
I really believe that because I think
it's what are you judging like cool you
made 83 million dollars in a bank and
you die and nine people show up to your
funeral was like that good I would argue
it's not why is kindness so important to
you well because at 47 it's clear to me
that that's an equal variable to work
ethic that's brought me to the place
that I'm at there are times where I find
myself saying things like ah this this
person's a no any really own kindness I
think it's understanding negativity
versus cutting it out we're all humans I
mean I'm gonna go to the Garden tonight
and the things I'm gonna say to Jimmy
Butler are going to be completely
inappropriate though I love Jimmy Butler
it's the context like every human's
gonna gossip a little bit I think the
question becomes why you know I ask
myself why do I not spend a lot of time
tearing down other people it starts with
because I'm not tearing down myself